[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN LABARGE: I'm going to
talk about doing some Mobile
DevOps on GCP.
It's a bit of a unique talk
that I'm using some of the tools
here to do serverless builds of
Android apps and distribution.
I actually will show
some code and whatever,
and if that's what you're
here for, that's good.
Might be one of the
more technical talks.
I'm not sure.
So the first thing
to get started
is I'm going to talk about
our little application.
I've built a little
application that's
going to take the
world by storm.
Not really, because I'm a
developer and an ops person,
not a designer.
Some of the GUI
is not that fancy.
But I just built a little
note-taking application.
And the idea is we're
going to simulate--
we're going to build
this application
and continually iterate
on it, make changes to it,
and run it through a DevOps
pipeline and see what happens.
So a little idea.
This is the sad GUI
that we have going on.
We can take the
little text notes.
And we want to add image
notes to our application,
but they're not done yet.
So we're going to merge a
feature and see what happens.
Hopefully you all can
see the text well enough.
If you look at the
bottom, there's
like a little terminal
window in Android Studio.
So not a whole lot to see
here, but what I'm going to do
is try to merge a
feature branch in here.
And just go ahead and--
I want to make sure.
We've got lots of changes.
I guess it automerged.
And so I'm going to go
ahead and push that code up
to the repository.
Wi-Fi is getting slower
by the minute, I guess,
as people arrive.
But there we go.
So that's all I'm going to do
on the application for now.
I can show it to you as well.
It's just a little
note-taking application.
You can add text note, create
a note, you can edit it a note.
Everything's stored in Firebase.
And that's how it works.
All right, so now let's talk
about DevOps for a minute.
Some lovely quotes here.
"DevOps is not a goal, but
a never-ending process."
It is how most of us by now
in the past like three or four
years are used to working.
We want to get stuff-- features
in in the hands of our testers
or our constituents
in the company
and get iteration faster,
find the bugs faster,
shorten the loop.
And so in this, what
I'm going to demonstrate
is a dogfooding pipeline,
where basically we're
building and testing internally,
developing, pushing stuff
to a repository,
and then sending out
apps to our dogfooders.
What dogfood means
at Google is sort
of folks internally testing
our applications before we
release them, which I think is a
fairly common term in industry.
And so with mobile, DevOps
is a little bit funky,
because unlike web, we've
got to sign this binary.
We have to create the binary.
We have to sign the binary.
We have get the
binary to the users,
and they have to install
it from somewhere.
And there's lots of
extra stuff going
on there that's not like web.
We can't just build a
new Docker container
and launch it into Kubernetes.
We have to actually
physically deliver
a binary to the mobile user.
But we can still do that
using this fun new product--
old product-- renamed product
called Cloud Build, which
was originally termed
Container Builder
and meant to be used to
build Docker containers,
and maybe deployed into
Kubernetes and things
like that.
It turns out, what we
learned about Cloud Build is
that we can build
anything, and the community
taught us that the most.
There's a Cloud
Builders repository
which I'll show you that
has many different types
of builders for Cloud Build.
But back to Mobile DevOps.
So this is a flow
for Mobile DevOps.
We trigger some build.
We test the build.
At least, a smoke
test on the build.
And distribute that
binary, and then maybe we
monitor for crashing
or other analytics.
So it starts with developers.
Hopefully it starts
with a repository
we're all putting our code in.
I think that's a pretty
known commodity nowadays,
but if you're not using
a source code repository,
you probably should
look into that.
And then we're going to
trigger a Cloud Build process.
And these are the repositories
currently supported
by Cloud Build.
You can use Google Cloud Source
Repo, which I'm using here--
GitHub, or BitBucket.
This is what it looks like
to create a Build trigger.
There's basically three steps.
You pick out the Source
Control Repo you're using,
you select the
specific repository,
and then you set
up your trigger.
When you set up your trigger,
you can pick out a branch.
You can obviously name your
trigger, pick out a branch,
or a tag.
So you can trigger based on tag.
I'm using a branch here
kind of a la GitFlow,
but you could just as easily
use a tag, which might actually
be a little bit better
for your specific case.
And this is how you
trigger the build,
which is what I just did.
So building the binary,
again we were triggering
a build in Container Builder--
or Cloud Build, rather.
I'm going to mess that up a lot.
And that build is described by
this funky magic file called
cloudbuild.yaml.
And that is what describes every
step that you want to take,
just like you would in your--
if you're in Jenkins, then
you have list of steps.
You would have that.
This is the description
of the list of steps
that the Cloud Build will take
in order to build your binary
and test it and do whatever
else you want to do.
And in this case, we're
going to push source code.
And the steps are
going to be described
in the cloudbuild.yaml.
And the results
of our Cloud Build
is going to be a distribution
through Fabric or Crashlytics
data, which is going to
end up emailing our users
about the new application.
That slide didn't show up right.
Sorry.
OK.
So the Cloud Build
workflow is again,
a bunch of steps that
operate on your workspace.
So when that trigger
happens, Cloud Build
pulls the source
code and drops in all
in a workspace directory,
just like Jenkins.
That probably sounds familiar
to anybody who's used Jenkins.
And then it runs a
bunch of build steps.
The thing that's interesting
about it is that all of those
build steps are containers.
And the commands they're
in are contained.
All of their dependencies are
contained in Docker containers
and images.
And so in this case, we're
doing a gsutil, copy stuff
from Cloud Storage,
an Android build,
another test using
the gcloud command,
and some more Android build.
Each one of those steps is
its own Docker container.
So you're actually calling
Docker Run in order
to complete that step
in the workspace.
And like I said before, there's
a rich set of those containers
in the community site.
You can find stuff--
the Android container is
the one I'm discussing here,
which is contributed by me.
But it's open source, so
if you have edits and PRs,
you can issue PRs to it.
But there's, as
you can see, a ton
of different containers for
doing builds and deployments.
There's one for, for
instance, create gcloud.
You can even create compute
instances and everything
like that.
There's one for
kubectl if you're
deploying a Kubernetes
manifest, deploying a Kubernetes
infrastructure.
And there's one
there that's called
Dataflow Python, which
as you can imagine,
is meant for setting
up a Dataflow job.
So there's just lots
of possibilities.
So in using the Android
Builder, what you're going to do
is build the container that's
going to run the Android build.
So it's going to have the Gradle
and Java SDK and the Android
SDK.
And in order to build that
up, what we want to do
is we want to build a container
that's relatively lean.
So we don't want to necessarily
include every Android
SDK from the beginning of
time to now in that Docker
container, because it would take
a really long time to pull that
from the registry.
So in order to semi-customize
and package an Android builder
for your own needs, you edit
this packages.text file,
which specifies all
the packages you
want in your Android Builder.
And every time you create
a new Android Builder,
you can change the
packages you're using.
Now the Android
builder also requires
you to supply your license
key from your workstation.
So in your Android
SDK home, you're
going to have a
licenses directory,
so you can supply
your Android SDK
license from there as a build
substitution in Container.
But I'll show you
that in a minute.
But so each of these would
have to have the EULA already
accepted, and then the license
key hash that you supplied
to Container
Builder will already
know that you have
accepted the license
and it will can
continue to build.
And so after that,
this is the steps.
You clone the repo.
You create the packages.text
file in that directory,
and then you submit the Android
Builder's cloudbuild.yaml file,
which is going to build a
container in your Google
Cloud's Container Registry.
That's going to have the
Android Builder piece,
and you can just go ahead
and call that from your apps
build, which I'll go through.
So that's the three steps.
And then the result is
you have this Android
Builder in your registry.
If you want more information
on the Android Builder and more
specifically, there's a
document drafted by me
on creating this pipeline in
more detail on our website,
so you can hit up
this document and it
goes through all of the
steps for setting up
the Android Builder.
So you don't have to
remember everything
that I'm saying here.
I'm just trying to give
you an introduction.
But here's some more
details that you're probably
looking for.
So in getting more
detail about what
we need to do to
build the mobile app,
we are going to need to
sign the Android application
with a Keystore file, right?
Everyone who is an
Android developer
probably is familiar with that.
And so the way we approach
that in this, is we just
go ahead and copy all of
the signing information
to a storage bucket.
And that storage
bucket will only
be accessible from the project
that you're using to build.
And you could secure that even
further with key management,
but that's out of scope here.
You copy your Fabric secrets
up to a different bucket
or the same bucket.
And there's an extra little
optimization here called
the build cache,
which sort of tries
to optimize the dependencies for
Gradle so it's not downloading
the internet all the way
from the internet, but maybe
downloading the internet closer
to where CloudBuild lives.
And then we move on
for our test items.
The other thing to note here
is the arguments in each one.
Those are actually arguments
to the Docker run entry point.
And you can change
the entry point.
None of these actually
change the entry point.
But you can change the entry
point on these containers
to just sort of execute
arbitrary Bash as well
and still have-- for
instance, let's say
in the gsutil I want to
just do arbitrary Bash.
I can add an entry point
in there, run that Bash.
But that Bash still has gsutil
in the path for that command.
So that Bash command can
call any of the dependencies
from the gsutil
container, for instance.
So this is sort of how
you put together a build.
The other thing to note here
is the substitutions we have.
Any of these shell variables
with an underscore in the front
is what we call a
substitution in CloudBuild.
And what that is, is a
value you supply when you
configure the build trigger.
So you can update,
you can basically
parameterize your build.
So the signing API's
secret bucket path
is where to find
fabric.properties
in Cloud Storage.
It's actually a gs://uri.
The license is whatever
you copy and paste it
in for the license.
There's a new version
pending, by the way,
where you can copy all
of your Android licenses
to another bucket and use
a bucket reference instead.
That's a PR that's been
submitted and currently
pending.
And then another parameter
to mention here is waitFor.
waitFor is how you
wait for other things.
So you need your signing
files, obviously,
before you build
the distribution
version of the app.
And so, you're going to
want to wait for that copy
to complete before you
build the distribution file.
I'll have to go on
to the next slide
to show more dependencies,
but you get the idea.
So after we've built
the binary, in this one
we build the debug
version of the binary.
And then we're going to
test that debug version
with Firebase Test Lab, which
is a service that Firebase
provides that has actual
physical devices in a data
center that you can run both
robot tests and functional
tests on.
This pipeline specifically
deals with robo tests,
but you can also record and
create Espresso functional
tests, and run those tests on
the devices in the data center.
So it lets you run
detailed tests.
And you can see the results and
add workflow, and et cetera.
Oh, yes.
Let's take a look
at the devices.
So I pulled up a list of
devices recently from Test Lab.
So these are the devices you
can actually run your functional
and robo tests on.
There's quite a few of them.
Some of them are
virtual, you'll see.
But most of them,
the vast majority,
are actual physical devices that
your APK will be loaded onto.
The debug version of the APK
will be loaded onto and tested,
or the test APK as well
if you're using Espresso.
Let me switch.
And so, here's our
workflow again.
OK, so the Test Lab build
step is interesting.
So here is where I had to use
the Bash notion of, I'm running
GCloud, but I'm going
to wrap it in some Bash
to make sure because the
Test Lab command in GCloud
doesn't give me a good
status process exit code.
Wouldn't test pass or fail.
So I've added some
fanciness here to check
whether the test passed.
And there's a corrupt
statement further down.
But you can see more of the
waitFor up here in the build.
So you can see some more
of those waitFor arguments.
And this is sort of like some
screenshots from a robo test.
I can actually flip
over to the other laptop
and show you some of the
output of a robo test
if you're interested.
So here you can see,
this is some of the flow.
The robo test is kind of like
a random touch and type test.
And you can see I'm
using Firebase Auth.
I know this is a little small.
I can get into some screenshots.
But I'm using
Firebase Auth here,
which uses Google sign-in.
And actually, this thing
comes up with its own Google
account and signs in to
the app, and then starts
touching different
aspects of the app
just to see if anything crashes.
So let's say this Create
button was enabled in here.
Then when the robo test hits
Create with an empty string,
it might have caused
a null pointer.
And if that happened, the
test would have failed.
And you can also get a video
recording of your robo test
so you can go through and
see what the automation did.
And this is actually on a Pixel.
So it's getting the OAuth
screen, and then saying yes.
And then now it's got it open.
It's a little flickery
with the video,
but you can see sort of
what different screens
it's accessing and all of that.
It's sort of like
a blind person just
trying to break your
application, that's
the best way to describe it.
Going to flip back.
So the rest of the build is
trying to distribute our--
assuming the test pass, assuming
there's no failure in the robo
test, we're going to
want to send it out
to dogfooders for the folks
internally for further usage.
And so, that's what Fabric
Crashlytics is used for.
And in this case, I'm using
just a Gradle command for that.
You can actually
use fastlane here.
But Android developers
still like Gradle, I think.
Some are converting to fastlane.
I'm not really sure.
But this is, suffice to say,
a Gradle implementation.
So a couple of things to
note in this part of the
build is that we're
wrapping the Gradle
command with a script
that does that fancy grab
the cached jars from
the storage bucket,
and it copies the licenses
over that you supply.
The other things you see
here are substitutions.
So the build type is the beta
build type, in this case.
And the email distribution group
is the set of folks in Fabric
where I want to
email the build to.
And the upload
distribution build
type is the thing
that actually uploads
the APK to Fabric Crashlytics.
And then once that's
completely uploaded,
your users that are
your testers will
get an email notifying
them that there has been
an update to the application.
And so, this is sort of what
that tester UI looks like.
You can add emails for
different applications
you might have, and pick
out which of those groups
you want to email
your results to.
And you can have different ones.
Maybe you have different build
flavors or different build
types, depending on
who in the company.
You might have some that
just go to developers,
some that go to QA after that,
some that, after that, might
go to product managers.
And then, maybe, finally
the whole company.
So you can really
granularly adjust that.
Finally, what we do here
is this is Crashlytics.
And this is an actual bug
that I had in the code.
It's hard to see stack trace,
the call-in stack trace.
But I had a bug with
my Firebase access.
And this was one of
the notifications I got
from Crashlytics of the crash.
So you can-- once this
thing's out in the wild
or out to your users,
depending on who they are,
you can monitor for crashes.
So this is sort of
like a full serverless
pipeline where everything is
done using managed services.
There's nothing here that's
sort of an online thing you
have to keep up and running.
There's no Jenkins server,
there's no Kubernetes cluster
to keep up and running.
There's nothing to maintain.
It's all sort of when you
submit that new CloudBuild YAML,
it boots up that container
and starts running
all the Docker commands.
So that's sort of
the use case here.
Just a minute.
All right.
So a few minutes ago
I issued a build,
and we can see the
results of the build.
It was successful.
And this is sort of what
the output of our pipeline
looks like here.
You can see each command.
So this is running--
Ubuntu is just an arbitrary
shell running container.
So if I use Ubuntu, I can just
call like mkdir, or whatever,
stuff like that.
I've got a copy licenses step.
And I can just
page through here.
I'm not going to go
through everything.
The Test Lab one is interesting.
You can see that this one takes
a bit of time, five minutes,
to complete, which is why
I do that at the beginning,
and then wait until it finishes.
And you can see finally
that at the end of this,
there's a whole other build.
And at the end, it finally
sends it up to Fabrics.
There's actually two Gradle
builds that happen in here.
The first one is a debug
build for the robo test.
And robo test takes the debug
APK and does its testing on it.
And then finally,
it's push to Fabric.
And then from there I
get an email, hopefully,
if I can get my
beach ball to stop.
There we go.
I should get an
email to my user.
I'll just go on the--
Well, I should've
gotten an email here.
Interesting.
Maybe I'm sending
it to this one.
OK.
Yeah, so from there, my
users would get an email,
assuming this guy's a tester.
Maybe he's not.
I'm not sure.
I should have one on my phone.
OK, I have one on my phone.
Is it just this one?
Just pull this out?
Oh, here.
Oh, can we do this?
SPEAKER: I don't have it.
JOHN LABARGE: What's that?
JOHN LABARGE: Oh,
you don't have it?
Oh, OK.
Will it work if I just pull
this out and then put it here?
It may?
I've never really connected
an Android before.
Anyway, on my phone if
you're really interested,
I have an email from Fabric
with the new version.
And we can also take a look at
the robo test that occurred,
hopefully.
All right, so this is the
last set of robo tests
that just completed.
All right, so they look
pretty much the same
as the other ones.
But you can see
that this one just
happened about 20 minutes ago.
So that is, in a nutshell,
how to do serverless
managed DevOps with
Android on GCP.
It's CloudBuild plus
Firebase Test Lab.